bill gross the bond king one of the best
investors in the world at a specific
asset class in the financial markets he
previously was a bitcoin bear he thought
all cryptocurrencies were a scam but now
he has capitulated and bill gross is a
bitcoin investor here's the quote of
where he recently revealed his bitcoin
bet he said i simply think that you know
the crypto coins are a bubble i do think
that there are survivors i do think we
need an alternative to the dollar as
we've seen in the last week or two and
that you know there will be several
survivors and i'm invested to a small
extent in bitcoin now this is a complete
turn of events for bill gross he's known
as the bond king but now he's making
this bitcoin investment and so if we go
back and look the timeline of bill
wasn't exactly what you would expect
2017 he said that he thought bitcoin
prices could go up due to its limited
supply but it couldn't be a substitute
for currencies or gold in times of
economic distress sounds like he's
changing his mind in 2018 he also
tweeted a quote from the hong kong-based
investor jennifer zao scott at the world
economic forum in davos and suggested
that bitcoin isn't great as a currency
and may not be a good payment mode
either but bill gross is not alone in
being a bitcoin bearer that's
capitulating flipping and becoming a
bitcoin bull we also have seen citadel's
ken griffin go ahead and do the exact
same thing
recently ken griffin changed his tune
and he said crypto has been one of the
great stories in finance over the course
of the last 15 years and i'll be clear
i've been in the naysayer camp over that
period of time but the crypto market
today has a market capitalization of
about two trillion dollars in round
numbers which tells you that i haven't
been right on this call one of the signs
of intelligence is that when people get
new information they're willing to
change their mind if the situation calls
for it both bill gross and ken griffin
are doing exactly that these
billionaires understand that the world
is changing they're watching everything
from financial markets inflation and
geopolitical events unfold and
ultimately they're all reaching the same
exact conclusion that i and millions of
other people around the world have
reached bitcoin's good for business
bitcoin is going to be adopted globally
and ultimately bitcoin is safety when
you need it most hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time